what do you love about burgers burgers
are pure indulgence they're classic
diner food that makes me feel like a
true American it's cheesy its decadent
it's all these incredible flavors coming
together I love everything about a
hamburger I'm talking about top bottom
everything in between
I'm Keanu I'm Matthew and I will Lexus
and we're gonna show you our recipes for
the tastiest burger we've ever made you
ready to get boozy well it's time to
make my over-the-top
hefty meaty burger for making my burger
you're gonna want to start with the
longest cook time items first so we're
gonna start with the caramelized onion
you're gonna put some butter into a
cast-iron skillet and drop in some
sliced yellow onions these you want to
cook really low and slow until they
develop a large amount of flavor
these caramelized onions have a slight
pungency and a slight sweetness and it's
gonna add a lot of great warmth and
complexity to the burger overall a lot
of people love cheese with their burgers
but honestly I don't really like dairy
too much so I love to have an aioli
which is like a planned flavor and gives
me everything I want from cheese but
even more add one egg 1 egg yolk stone
ground mustard lemon juice salt pepper
and cayenne pepper then you're gonna
turn the food processor on and let it
whizz for a little bit and then you're
going to stream in 1 tablespoon of oil
and just let it kind of continue mixing
this is gonna start to create a strong
emulsion that will eventually create a
very thick mayonnaise like texture after
it blitz is for a few seconds and you
can see it start to thicken a little bit
add in the rest of your oil then it's
gonna be like a magical process where it
goes from a complete liquid to a super
thick creamy condiment such as aioli
it's kinda like Mayo but better
[Music]
for my burger meat I like to use 50%
sirloin and 50% chuck the reason I do
this is sirloin is known for having a
super deep complex beefy flavor but some
people think it can be a little bit
tough
whereas chuck is a little bit more fatty
tender subdued so the combination of
both is gonna give me a very strongly
flavored beefy burger as well as one
that's still juicy and tender when it
comes to the meat and fat ratio for the
meat I like 80% protein and 20% fat so
once you have your ground beef mixed
together I want to be 1/2 a pound
because I'm not here for no skimpy
burger it's really important to get it a
little bit bigger than the size of your
bun that way when it cooks it kind of
shrinks down to be the exact same
diameter and I press down the center to
get a little bit of a bevel that way
when the burger cooks it ends up being a
flat burger once you have all your
patties ready make sure your cast iron
is really hot I had a little bit of
butter into the pan and then I place
down the burger for my burgers I like to
just put it in the pan and cook it until
it has a nice char on one side I flip it
over once more until the other side is
good to go and then it comes right off
after you take the burgers out of the
pan it's time to toast your beautiful
pretzel buns the reason why I like
pretzel buns is because you have a
crispy top and if you toast the bun in
the same pan you have a crispy bottom
and allows all that flavor from the beef
fat to soak into your bun okay and now
it's time to assemble this honker take
the bottom bun smear on some ketchup put
on your beautiful caramelized onions
place the charred juicy burger your
butter lettuce thinly sliced tomato
pickled onion don't worry about those
electrodes or show you how to make those
in a bit then put the aioli and that is
time to eat
the reason I love my burger is because
it's a perfect balance of flavors
textures and temperatures I'm a
Midwestern boy so I love a burger that's
gonna make me full I want to be hefty
and I want to be able to taste each and
every bite so this is my perfect
decadent burger but if you want
something extremely flavorful you have
to try kimonos because her dozen be like
really flavorful god that's on camera if
you want a burger that you can't buy in
any restaurant and you have to try
making my burger my philosophy for
making a really really good hamburger is
uniformity everything should be the same
throughout that way every single bite is
just as delicious from beginning to end
tomato onion are notorious for slipping
and sliding out of burgers so to resolve
that I make a tomato jam tomato jam is
so great because it replaces three
essential items to your burger it serves
as a ketchup it's a tomato and it's the
onion all in one delicious spread you
chuck it all in a pot bring it to a boil
then you turn it down and let it bubble
away for about a half-hour second sauce
is really simple equal parts Dijon
mustard and a good-quality mayonnaise
mix well together let it hang out until
it's ready to assemble the bun is what
holds this whole perfect beautiful
burger together I like using that
classic you know burger bun those little
white sesame seeds on top I think
probably could use reminding my
childhood and they're just really cute
all it needs is a nice healthy spread of
butter and a little bit of time on that
cast-iron pan just enough to get golden
brown only on the inside they don't
toast the outside then I pop them aside
until
I appreciate all kinds of meat for my
burger but beef still king for me 80%
20% fat the important part for me is the
size of the patty in order to have a
nice uniform burger the patty needs to
be equal size to the bun however once
the patty goes on to the pan it's gonna
shrink a little bit
so I sheet made patty to be one inch
wider in diameter then my buns so once
it shrinks down it should be nice and
even on the sides so once my patties are
ready to go I cook them in a very hot
cast-iron skillet just long enough so
it'll golden crust forms on one side
flip it once but never press otherwise I
press out all the juice and a be a
driver burger and nobody likes to drive
after the cheese is on add a little bit
of water to the pan and pop on the lid
what this does it creates is nice you
know little steamy spa for the burger
where cheese can melt quickly without me
worrying about that burger drying out my
preferred cheese is a classic white
English cheddar it's strong enough yet a
little bit of nuttiness and oh man this
is so good
cooking the burger patty has to be the
very last stop this ensures that when
that burger hits the table it is still
hot and juicy and so they're so good
otherwise it'd be a nice little cute
local burger I could be old I'm talking
about like I ain't got no teeth old I
would need somebody to make me a pair of
dentures just so I can eat a burger as
my last meal on earth and that that's
how much I love burgers so ok ha the
tastiest burger I've ever made is my
smash burger I'm pretty classic in terms
of my tastes and that is what this
burger is it's not fussy it's really
classic
and I don't know anyone who would like
I'm gonna start with the pickled red
onions I love these onions because
so easy to make they add this great
crunch and it's not too acidic it has
some sweetness so you can actually do
this before you make your burger so that
the time they're all fried up you're
ready to go at the apple cider vinegar
the water sugar and salt into a small
pan and bring it to a boil over high
heat and then take it off the heat add
the onions and just let it sit at room
temperature for 30 minutes to an hour
and you can use it that's it simple this
so moving on to the burger I'm gonna use
80/20 so there's two types of burgers a
diner style burger and a pub style
burger you can really see the difference
with a diner style burger it's about
four ounces and it's really it's much
smaller and flatter whereas a pub style
burger is much thicker so before forming
it into a patty shape you're actually
gonna form it into a bowl and season it
generously with salt and pepper I'm
gonna use a cast-iron pan because it's
gonna give a great crust add the ball to
the cast-iron and then immediately take
a spatula or two and press it down
flattening the burger I like a thin
burger because you really get the flavor
of that crispy exterior I also think it
lets your toppings shine a bit more so
after you cook it for 1 to 2 minutes
flip it over that's what I'm gonna add
the cheese so I want that cheese to
really melt and cover that burger you
get that any gooey feeling from here
just cook it another minute or two and
then immediately take it off the heat
the bun I like to use is a brioche bun
some people think it's too sweet but I
actually think the sweetness is really
nice with the fat and the cheese and the
pickles all these elements coming
together just toast it until it's golden
brown just like this oh my god it's
perfect in terms of condiments are still
gonna keep it classic I'm just gonna mix
some ketchup and mayo to build my burger
I'm going to put the ketchup and mayo
mixture on both buns at the lettuce add
the burger patty tomato pickled onions
there you go that's my burger it's very
simple this is a really quick simple
burger but that's what I like about it
you know fancy burgers are too
but when I crave a burger this is what I
picture so now that you've seen all of
our favorite burger recipes you have to
make one yourself at home or share what
your favorite recipe is in the comments
or really just much like mine you
kidding me make mine classic burger make
mine mine's incredible you're not even
trying to fight yeah because Irene I
already want
[Applause]
[Music]